The Joe Rogan Experience at some point
we should talk about the mad honey yeah
yeah well that's how you and I got in
touch recently right yeah uh you saw us
talking about mad honey on the show and
you reached out and said I'm actually
right now harvesting bad honey yes he
sent me a photo of you actually doing it
right there
I'm gonna grab some for my bag right now
and this mad honey you were in Tibet is
that where you get it from
this was in Nepal Nepal very close to
Tibet this is it now this looks like
store-bought honey because there's a
label on there what that truly is is I
transferred the honey to this grocery
store bottle so if I went through
customs I wouldn't have any issues good
move but that is that is the same honey
I showed you in the video so if you if
you look at it you can open it up
you'll see a couple things you'll see
it's a little bit more liquidy than
typical honey typical golden you know in
the bottle shaped like a bear honey and
this is supposed to be the honey that
makes your trip Falls yeah does it so I
think we should try it in a moment in a
moment are you willing to try it yeah
I'll try right now don't try it right
now okay okay hold on a little bit of
build up a little bit of backstory
sorry I'm very controlling it's okay so
you see you see it's soupy you see it's
red yes I went to Nepal
um some people know how this works
already these uh the honey I think I
just think we should explain where the
Honey comes from right the Honey comes
from these Cliffs
um there's different places around the
world do you have a video of you doing
it yet or is it not released yet not
really but we can find a video of uh
them harvesting mad honey because it's
really fascinating how they have to do
it yes so I it was about maybe a 12 hour
drive from the capital of Kathmandu that
we went to this Village of maybe 500
people and we joined these these guys as
they collected the honey and they don't
have like honey boxes the honey is on
the mountain sides and they basically
risk their lives taking these ladders
they have these ladders these rope
ladders and the reason they need rope
ladders is because they need to be able
to hike sometimes up to several hours to
go to where the honey is whoa the
Honey's not conveniently located it's
located wherever the hell the bees put
it
and so they they take these rolled up
ladders and they they string it on the
cliff they climb the ladders or descend
from the ladders and then they have to
carefully use these long sticks to cut
the honeycomb off of the Mountainside
before doing that they put some pegs
into the honeycomb so this is like a big
flat protruding honeycomb coming from
the Mountainside and then eventually
they cut it off and they lower it down
the people
on the bottom then collect the honey and
they can start to process it
what so there's a couple things that are
interesting here one is like the
collection process which is dangerous
and just kind of unbelievable I mean one
of the scariest you see all these bees
here I had to wear the bee hat everyone
Nobody messes around everyone wears the
b-hat as soon as they get the smoke
going these bees go insane and you see
thousands of bees stinging the [ __ ] out
of everything and everyone trying to get
it through people's clothing and you
know when bees sting their stinger comes
out right so it's all just a Kamikaze
mission for all these different bees
and so all these people are getting
stung
um so they had the appropriate clothing
by their hands the guy my guide who
wasn't used to being there got about
four B's inside the hat and that's never
what you want and so their solution was
that to that was to reach to his hat
inside the net and pinch the bees inside
rather than trying to get them out they
just killed him inside oh and so when
they they got the honey for example you
could see here they're dumping it out of
the basket there's gonna be tons of Bees
and Honey mixed together when I flew my
drone there I landed the Drone and it
was wet with B body parts I must have
shredded a thousand bees just with my
drone wow so they are on the defense and
before you go there
before you put the smoke the honeycomb
is black because it's completely covered
by the bees but after the smoke comes up
it reveals the actual yellow honeycomb
underneath
so that's one interesting aspect to this
so the smoke is to try to calm down
these bees right to repel them to make
them leave so how do they do that they
start fires at the base of the cliff yes
and these guys are so badass they know
how to start a fire and basically put it
into a makeshift backpack and then Carry
It Out Boy so they're carrying smoke on
their back and then dumping it dumping
it at the base of the cliff and and then
the smoke goes up and then the bees go
insane from there is it because the bees
know
um are they accustomed to people trying
to steal their honey I do think it puts
them in a defensive mode uh but also
just like a lot of insects don't like
smoke so it's like
they know they have to leave because
there's smoke but they want to protect
the hives at all costs so
that's one aspect the other aspect is
the the hallucinogenic light-headed
effects that are purported to come from
eating the honey
so how does that happen the bees collect
uh I forget if it's nectar or pollen
from certain types of flowers that grow
there locally and these flowers have
some kind of chemicals inside it creates
a neurotoxic effect
in your brain when you eat it so I
interviewed a villager this is why I
want to build up a little bit so you can
see how about trying the honey you still
are but I think we should still
absolutely do it together
I went to a villager there I was
thinking everyone's just going to be
jacked up on honey all the time and it's
a great time and so I talked to this guy
he was the one who owned the cliff where
the the honey is and I said how often do
you do it he goes I did it 20 years ago
that's the last time
I said can you walk me through the
experience he said I took a lot and I
couldn't walk for 24 hours
oh you couldn't walk okay that's pretty
extreme I've heard similar stories from
people while I was there and it seemed
interesting because
at least in the village I went to I know
it's different in different parts of
Nepal but at least where I went people
seemed like I've done it and I'm good
and they didn't really want to do it
much more so why are they collecting it
well there's a big Market in places like
Japan and especially Korea they said
where people want to
um by the honey and and eat the honey
which is interesting because I looked it
up and it's it's actually illegal in
Korea it said so this brings me to
that day I tried a bit I tried about a
spoon and I got scared about trying too
much because we still had to hike an
hour out of there then a three hour
drive I'm like I need to use my legs
but my brother my brother joined me my
brother Scott joined me at a hotel in
Saint Cloud recently about a week and a
half ago and he knew I had the honey
because I talked about bringing it here
and he's like I want to try the honey
and he's a bit of a hater and he's like
it's [ __ ] honey what's gonna happen
and I gotta go to bed because I got work
to do the next day and so I'm in his
room across her mind in the hotel and I
give him a couple spoons and I'm like
you should just do a couple spoons wait
30 minutes and see how you feel he goes
uh yeah no just give give me more you're
going to sleep soon just give me more if
I want more I'll take it so while I'm
still there he takes more maybe five six
spoons
then I go all right I gotta go to bed
have a good time let me know actually I
said why don't you text me
the effects during the evening and I'll
know what to expect when I do it
so here's what he said
I've got this text right here feels good
warm warm breath
he goes on totally legit all right hater
Vibes gone
my body's on fire in a very positive way
it's weird my scalp feels hot my muscles
tingle
so far good
might get nauseous take less
I can't tell
not good
regret
[Music]
very bad
just don't
stupid
I keep hoping I'm done I'm so sick
at 5 40 AM
I should maybe eat a banana
so that's my brother
so how much in total did he take six
spoons
six of this spoon I brought this spoon
because I want I needed like a
measurement system right that was
accurate I'm like I need to know exactly
which spoon you basic plastic ice cream
spoon yeah and so this is not a deep big
spoon this is not a tablespoon it took
six of those yeah about six so I think
we should try it out and maybe it sounds
like [ __ ] that's terrible no but if you
do too much it's [ __ ] are you sure
we gotta find out Joe but do we have to
find out here how long does it take uh I
think we'll still be over before we
really feel it how much time do we have
left oh as long as you want really
um why not try a little bit okay let's
try a little bit try a little bit I I
don't know if you want to share this
plastic spoon I also brought these these
are a little bit deeper okay this is
what I think I should use a regular
spoon this one oh it doesn't matter I
was gonna use the spoon that was used
okay you just so you got to mix it up
first okay mix it up real good I mixed
it up before coming here but it
separates I'm not sure what's separating
it's very liquidy it's very different
than honey
like regular honey I'm just gonna have a
little bit smell like honey
it tastes like honey too do a whole
spoon no I'm gonna do a half spoon okay
you got plans tonight yeah I gotta show
I gotta do I can't have fake legs my
legs aren't moving fake leg wow it feels
weird yeah so don't drink any water
uh I'll take a little bit too
it definitely feels different than
regular honey I think I took too much
yeah
let's find out
so
you want to put the lid on it sure
I'll leave this one here for you thank
you you can try it on your own time the
first thing I experience you don't want
to leave me alone to try things on my
own time I've gone down dark roads do
you feel anything because right away I
feel it in the back of my throat yeah I
feel the back of my throat itchy like I
want a cough I want to clear my throat
yeah it's um
it's almost got like a
H it's not hot like uh hot peppers but
it's got like that feeling like you're
reacting to it almost like a hot pepper
a little bit hmm
like oh
yeah yeah like I want to cough when I
have it sorry so I'm told
at least by this guy in the mountain in
Nepal
don't drink any water he's like you're
just gonna want to drink more and more
and look I don't know if this is like a
redneck like mountain
bro speak Bro Science but he said
if you sorry ah yeah I'm feeling it at
least here in my throat I'm feeling it
how did your brother feel after it was
all over he so this guy said if you
drink water
you're just going to want to keep
drinking more and more water and you'll
never stop drinking water and you'll
make you more sick I don't know so my
brother felt hungover the next day
uh he felt stiff he said that so what
happens is it can lower your blood
pressure
and and I think that's what makes it
difficult to move and to walk
so your next question might be why the
[ __ ] do people want to take this right I
don't know
I couldn't figure it out and so I think
maybe in the right dose like too much of
anything is bad a little bit of cough
syrup great the whole bottle I did that
one time huge mistake yeah you know when
you watch the news and they're like hey
kids are doing this and they shouldn't
be and you're like [ __ ] you're gonna die
from cough syrup right I was like I want
to do that and I did it and it was like
the worst 24 hours of my life
I think a little bit of honey in your
tea at night might calm you down it
might be soothing
I'm not sure but to me it's unclear why
people are into it folks in Korea seem
to like it a lot at least that's what I
learned in Nepal
um so they what's the recommended dose
yeah that's the tricky part there's not
one there's not one and then there's no
um there's no way of figuring out like
how potent you know it's not like when
you buy marijuana edibles you can figure
out how many milligrams can you really
well at least it's a rough estimate
right here it says mad Honey's been
commonly used as an aphrodisiac sexual
stimulant in alternative therapy for
gastrointestinal disorders peptic ulcer
disease dyspepsia and gastritis and for
hypertension for a long time see uh what
the recommended dose
of mad honey is so they're selling a
bunch of mad honey online but is that
real or is a lot of it phony baloney
it's hard to say and you know that's the
trouble I had even when I was there and
luckily I had to fix her a local
producer who I could really trust and he
said it's a real deal and I trust him as
soon as I tried it I felt something like
you know I felt in my throat I felt did
you feel your face get a little bit warm
or flush no no I think it didn't take
enough maybe hopefully but hopefully
the place but Matt hein.net is one to
three tablespoons but and then please
read carefully each of us is unique our
body chemistry genetics tolerance
lifestyle and environment makes us all
very different for every person
finding the appropriate mad honey amount
is a personal individual process and as
such there is no one-size-fits-all dose
like Edibles yeah like Edibles Jamie can
eat Edibles all day long I could
probably have the whole jar yeah you
should try it I'm gonna leave it here I
have two jars I have one in my suitcase
I don't know what I'm going to do with
it and maybe I'll find this perfect
ratio and I'll uh it'll be the perfect
sleeping aid
um but I do think there's probably a lot
of [ __ ] online because how hard
would it be to take this mix it with 10
gallons of honey and be like yeah it's
mad yeah whatever put a little red dye
in there yeah our friend The Beekeeper
Erica what's her last name
quick sorry sorry no worries we had a
local beekeeper on recently it was
really fascinating very interesting
conversation and she was saying that a
lot of honey that you buy particularly
honey from overseas is not really honey
it's like partly honey but they mix it
in with corn syrup and this is I think
America Thompson just like maple syrup I
think most of the honey in the U.S is
that like corn syrup most of it really I
think so but I'm basically that's based
on [ __ ] nothing that's just my
intuition she said you have to buy local
honey buy local honey from local
beekeepers I totally agree do it yeah
yep so um that's it but you feel good
now right yeah I feel fine is there a
time where you would try more to see
what it did yeah I'll try more of this
you know if I get out of this okay oh I
think you'll be fine I think you just
kind of taste it a little bit yeah so
you know I'll try a full tablespoon
um for me I when I had it in the
mountain I didn't hallucinate but I
lights seemed a bit more Vivid and like
if I looked at lights like the lights
behind you and looked away they were
still kind of in my vision it's just
fascinating that the locals are like I
did it 20 years ago I'm good yeah well
right and that's what made me even more
apprehensive about trying it yeah
so